JOONAS KORPISALO WAS ON THE
OPPOSITE END.
THE THIRDRD WINDS AROUND.
AND THEY SCORE! CHEMISTRY
WE
JESPER BRATT, HE LOOKS
GUESS WHO?
OLIVER BJORKSTRAND, HIS TRYING
AND COLLECTS.S
TO THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
OPENING MINUTES OF THE SECONDPO
PICKED THEM UP AND PLAY!
A TIED GAME.
>> THE KIDEEPS IT ALIVE
AND KEEPS IT DOWN LOW,SCORES!
DOUGIE HAMILTON, LET IT RIP! TO.
HE LET'S A ROCKET GO. BLOCKED.
DEVILS HOLD THE ZONE. TY IN
BACK COMES SILLINGER FOR
INTO THE DEVILS ZONE, AND TY
SMITH ABLE DID, COLE SILLINGER.
>> PROBABLY KNEW A LOT OF REAL
BACK, OUT SHOOTING COLUMBUS HER.
SEVERSON WITH SOME TIME HERE.
SMSMK.
HE HAD TIME.
AND THE BLUE JACKETS C C JERSEY
WAS OUT SCORED, AND THERE
SESSION. AGAIN.
A SHOT OFF THE GLASS.
>> WOW.
THIS IS
SCRAMBLE FOR THE PUCK OFF DUPLI.
SHOOTING THIS SHOT.
>> DOUGIE HAMILTON, SAVES.
>> PATRIK LAINE HAS A GOAL THIS
AFTERN
NATIONAL ROOKIE FROM
NEW VORACEK.
CAN HE